I know you're a warlock Magnus I'm a
Shadowhunter Shadowhunters has been
renewed for a second season ET sat down
with Harry Shum Jr who plays Magnus Bane
on the hit series based on the Mortal
Instruments books have you been really
excited about the fan reception because
people seem to really love your
portrayal of the character but they're
so positive and they're you know this
character means so much it was really
important for me to to make sure that I
represented in the right way so because
it means so much for the fans and I
wanted to to be able to not only as
exterior but also the interior and get
him right whether it be his voice even
within the movement the physicality and
they've been really receptive all done
for today how much time do you spend in
like hair and makeup and everything for
that character it seems like they're too
long probably more than two Logan oh
girl love that yes I had to get a
cushion to sit down on because my butt
was hurting from sitting down tried to
like figure out different techniques on
like how to be a little more comfortable
black okay I mean I gained so much more
respect from for people who put on
makeup and obviously women put on makeup
but I had to put a lot more than most
women heads it just because it was more
eyeshadow and glitter and my hair was
doing crazy things so are you taking
glitter home everyday it's funny because
the cast they would know where I was
because I would leave winter trails so
they could follow me anytime you can
catch Harry as Magnus Tuesday nights on
freeform